-You play a police officer
in this film.
Yeah.
-Based on the clip,
you do not possess
great intelligence.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
My niche is an actor is to play
very stupid people.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I'll take it.
-Does this -- Now, there are
two kinds of stupid.
There's stupid with awareness
that they're stupid,
and then stupid without.
Is this --
-I specialize in without.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's too stupid
to even know they're stupid.
Yeah, like you mentioned
"Baby Mama."
-Yeah.
-So the difference between
this character and "Baby Mama"
is I have a mustache in this.
-That's it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and a different shirt.
Like I wore a lot of flannel
shirts in "Baby Mama",
and here I'm obviously
in some kind of municipality.
I don't know what that is,
but, yeah.
-You -- one of your --
-Are you impressed
with that mustache?
-It is a good mustache.
Is it your own?
-It is my own.
-Yeah.
-And I got to say,
I was nervous while growing it
that it would be
less than powerful.
And then when I saw the movie
for the first time
a couple weeks ago --
-It's great.
-It's a very powerful mustache.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that -- in your illustrious
career, is that the first time
you've grown your own mustache
for a role?
-It is.
-Wow!
-And I very much wanted --
I've been looking forward,
hoping --
Certain dreams have gone away.
-Yeah.
-I'm not going to get hired
to play a superhero.
-You think that window
is closed?
-I had always secretly thought,
"oh God, I hope I get
hired to play a superhero.
I can do steroids."
-Yeah.
-You know?
[ Laughter ]
-And --
-I'd like to try it as a man.
-Yeah.
-But have an excuse.
I'm a father of two. I can't
just do steroids for fun.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But for several million
dollars...
-Yeah, you would do steroids.
-I can do it. Yeah, yeah.
Or like a coke addict.
[ Laughter ]
-You want to play a coke addict?
-Yeah, I mean, I've been sober
for 13 years.
But I feel like if, like,
Scorsese calls and says,
"I got this great role for you.
You just got to huff
a lot cocaine."
-Yeah.
-I'd have to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-I bet they use prop cocaine.
I feel like --
-Not Scorsese.
-Yeah. That's true.
[ Laughter ]
-No, come on.
Maybe Spielberg,
but not Scorsese.
-But, so, then you got to
do the mustache.
Did you have enough time?
Like when you got offered
the part to when you
started shooting,
were you worried
it was too small a window?
-I was. In fact, it's a little,
how do we say,
inconsistent because it was
growing as we were filming.
-Ah.
-So there are some scenes
where it's a proper womb broom.
[ Laughter ]
And then there are others
where it's more just like
a pre-teen.
-Got it.
-Right. But funny enough,
the whole reason I'm in the
movie is that Vincent D'Onofrio
who's also in the movie,
much better actor than me.
-Fantastic actor.
I would say even,
but he's a fantastic actor.
-Yeah, one of the best.
-Yes.
-One of the greats.
Gets to play smart people
all the time.
They always hire him for that.
He texts me,
"Hey, we're starting a movie
in two weeks,"
because he read the script.
He said,
"This guy's dumb,
got to get Dax."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-He told the director.
He said,
"Yeah, he's as dumb as it gets."
[ Laughter ]
And it was, you know --
so it just happened.
Like, D'Onofrio actually
cast me in this movie.
-That's great.
-And then he said,
"I'm growing a mustache for it."
And I said,
"Well, then I'm going to, too."
And just to kind of mess
with him,
and, you know, here we have it.
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah.
The movie's called
"Mustache Christmas" --
[ Laughter ]
Please check it out
December 8th on Netflix.
-And its --
You play two police officers,
but your mustaches
solve the crime.
You're just, like, there.
-That's right. That's right.
That's right.
-I want to talk --
-Like the tea leaves.
I put dust in them.
And then I start
connecting the dots.
Genius mustache.
-At one point there's yarn.
Your mustache has yarn
connecting different --
-Connected to other parts.
-Yeah.
-And someone goes, "Oh, my gosh.
That's a map of El Camino!"
-Yeah.
And that's how you solve it.
-That's right.
-Well, we've given away
the film now.
-Yeah. You know,
you can skip it.